[Music]
but it is too late Karen is gonna be
waiting he coaches in dust check wads
[Music]
reactions
I don't think so I think this was just
kind of a long leg of just a kind of
just bad luck and bad playing from us
you know though you said liquid bringing
he code we're hoping he's kind of a sort
of the lineup out obviously I think he
brings so much to that team that could
obviously turn them around and make them
a little stronger unit we do have a few
players quite typed up here from
luminosity so he co definitely not going
down without a fight
oh well there's the first power strike
you go get us a double they still do
players that we got know how
Oh Mike in his holiday
[Applause]
once again the first base is the
trainees gonna hit the ground there's
cold just like data cheap though versus
for I think it's liquid out the door
because their run
I'm good luck and good fate in majors is
it over if I get on a team together
that's great and we can deal with this
later but you know it's something now
that I have to think about more than
ever now is what what do I want to do
after I'm done playing
keep it safe
right now to do this closer it's got
less than 10 HP silliman MA
[Music]
spencer hiko martin has pretty much been
playing counter-strike since it came out
regarded as one of North America's
longest standing OG top tier talents
he's known to be one of the smartest
players his region has ever seen the
problem is that he's also Bar None the
unluckiest you see for as long as he's
been alive he goes had the makings of a
cutthroat competitor but rarely the
results born and raised in Detroit
Michigan he Co spent his childhood
hopping from sports to sport until a
hockey injury turned his attention
towards a different sort of game and
when he was around 12 he encountered the
game that would change his life middle
school I was playing a game playing
Starcraft in Diablo 2 and I wasn't like
a group of friends and then one of the
guys brothers introduced him to Counter
Strike and he started playing Congress
like every day and we kind of missed him
so he all started to play Counter Strike
and that's where I started eventually he
goes obsession with Counter Strike gave
him an opportunity I was on like random
teams in the Counter Strike I was
playing a little bit more and more and
then one of my friends told me to watch
a match between two sponsored
professional teams there's like 30,000
people watching this I was talking to my
friend about and he's like yeah these
guys are paid to play they have sponsors
they travel over the world just from
that one match I was like all right
that's what I want to do but as with
most aspiring gamers the path that led
hiko to eSports wasn't direct hiko's
life took a turn when his father's famed
clothing store began to suffer amid
Detroit's economic struggles in the mid
2000s so when this industrious
Midwestern boy with 30 grand and student
loans and a part-time job at a concrete
factory told his parents midway through
a computer science degree that he'd be
dropping everything to pursue
counter-strike full-time well it didn't
go over very well he came to me and he
said I'm going to quit
I'm going to become a professional video
game player and I looked at him like he
had lost his mind but he Co was
determined to live out his dream to
succeed on his own terms having made a
name for himself in 1.6 he Co entered
global Offensive with a bang at a time
when no one was taking North American
counter-strike seriously he Co yearned
to embody the kind of skill and smarts
that would set him apart from his region
his talons earned him a spot on
complexity gaming were alongside such
stars as nothing Shan gaara's and swag
he upset the indomitable French roster
very games to secure an astonishing top
four at sea esko's first ever major Oh
complexity I take my hats off to you
says absolutely brilliant play from
complexity a round of applause
the Americans have played so unamerican
they have outsmarted to worry they see
him the bomb will blow an NBK will go
down with the ship
it's 1642 complexity
[Applause]
[Applause]
the issue is that great as they were
complexity began to stagnate they made
top 8 at the next major in Katowice
before signing with cloud 9 ahead of ESL
one cologne and at that tournament
despite narrowly losing the
quarterfinals Kiko made the most iconic
shot of his career but it is too late
Garen is gonna be waiting he co charges
in Dustin's Kiko but C nines problems
persistent they were bursting with
talent had great chemistry and were
solidifying themselves as the best
roster in North America they just
couldn't close come the next major they
didn't even make it out of groups now
leaving Kiko inside his palm sign and he
wants to take the fight he doesn't want
to get sandwiched in he wants to fight
up a lot but now he's gonna have to be
forced back the smoke is just making it
impossible to dance I had shot a lot of
my stuff and that's still pretty good
now it's down to a two on 3jw waiting in
the middle has the a K in hand he's
waiting they line up
JW triple kill he ends up at 21 kills
all of my foot 32 and fnatic they knock
cloud nine out of dreamhack winter 2014
oh thanks I think this is just kind of a
long leg I'm just a kind of just bad
luck and bad playing from us yeah in
desperate need of a change
Kiko made the courageous decision to
leave cloud 9 in the hope that he'd be
able to find a group of like-minded
players whose sole goal was to win
hiko was widely regarded as having been
c9 s best player and he caught the
attention of the only other roster in
north america to perform internationally
one that boasted a skilled support
player exceptional igl adored oper and
one of the greatest prodigies the game
has ever seen i jumped at the
opportunity it was supposed to be the
most talent on one roster at any time I
had the context of the journey they were
interested in doing it I put all this
together we had a good deal we had just
qualified to go to the X Games event and
then all of a sudden everything just
failed we have some interesting
information info it looks as though some
pro players have been banned by volvo oh
okay
could be born kc foster dazed swag azk
steal r.i.p ladies and gentlemen oh what
a lot of people don't realize about the
infamous ibuypower match-fixing scandal
is how it affected hiko in addition to
costing him the chance to join a super
team and reignite one of counterstrikes
oldest greatest orgs evil geniuses it
left him lost and without a sense of
direction determined to give his career
another shot he co used his newfound
downtime as an opportunity to throw
himself into something he'd always been
extremely passionate about streaming yes
no now tragic as it was the iBUYPOWER
affair had a funny way of helping hiko
forced to find a new team he hopped from
one fledgling roster to another before
finding his way onto the CIS inflected
flipside tactics there he met an unruly
indescribably talented up-and-comer
one who became a very unlikely friend as
the bob timer takes no problem
Adrenaline's the one b2 and yeah angel
Wow angel just go beast mode like still
regarded as a talk to your talent he
goes nomadic season came to a close when
he got the opportunity to join Team
Liquid in the fall of 2015 the goal was
to create what never came to fruition
with iBUYPOWER
North America's first dominant the super
team unfortunately it didn't happen
right away in spite of hiko's veteran
presence liquid floundered for almost a
year after his arrival suffering
elimination after elimination it's gonna
be Forrest waiting in a great block his
profit after that is it takes 1 : n IP
will play the best-of-three decider
matches
the survived the first test and for
liquid well
Koopa death was always going to be
extremely tough for them packed off they
did be think considering good numbers
against two very top teams but I guess
this is how we would have predicted it
when we look at it on paper it didn't
help that liquid had developed a
reputation for choking while on the cusp
of victory as Edward is your last man
standing supreme play on the first map
this bomb is gonna go down it's a one
before it's good always play for now
m.49 has got a Molotov as well smoke
goes down he's on the other side of it
could make something of this you know
they're all three players are waiting
for me to the post room how is this
gonna go down this is insane
[Applause]
against Edward bomb planted spoke in
Edward that wall he goes out
[Applause]
keeping me alive now no one enjoys
throwing one rounds but this was
especially frustrating for he go you see
in addition to boasting above-average
mechanics and a deep understanding of
the game he developed a reputation over
the years for being exceptionally calm
in the clutch Bomber fans already been
happening for quite a while here so he
Co and Sean that's a good kill for nikah
but they realize to pre still in there
somewhere they're gonna try and go for
here they want to go all in Eco comes in
with another killing back to it you want
to that bomb so far take they gotta move
quick right now and going for it that if
yours is already happening are you
kidding me he's gonna fix up a trip like
cloud nine when it wants it even got to
the point where the community started to
memeing on him because of it no I'm not
kidding you that's all it is Anders was
like Kiko are you kidding me and so
that's just that's a stuck everyone has
to hiki oh are you kidding me inhuman
reaction this it goes back it just goes
and come 2016 a change was in order and
he Co enabled it to happen his
connection with the goat to be resulted
in liquid making one of the most
compelling and chaotic signings in csgo
needless to say it paid off smokes
septuple smokes in the same place
this is this is a paid job with simple
boasting the blue and whites and hiko
acting as a sort of mint or liquid
weren't just a force to be reckoned with
they were the greatest roster their
region had ever seen they went all the
way to the semi-finals of counterstrikes
first million-dollar major where it
became resoundingly clear that he co had
finally found a place where he could
shine now again as we see so many times
before astound to Higa but again spore
is it really possible we do have a few
players quite typed up here from
luminosity so he could definitely not
going down without a fight
oh well there's the first part right he
go gets a double there's still two
players that they got no help on them 13
and 3 he code creeping around the site
now there's still time it's all my
goodness how did he do this
but the second tragedy of hiko's career
struck in those semi-finals at what
should have been the end of the first
map the impossible happened and he Co
found himself on the receiving end of
the most infamous miraculous play in the
history of csgo
following this in this spot before the
same spot with but with much more
utility to work with here it comes once
again the first base is that trainees
gonna hit the ground there's cold they
need a huge play but that was something
I'm never gonna see ever again broken
and bewildered liquid began to unravel
finally after losing nine rounds in a
row the North American super squad
collapsed and that leaves everything to
hiko again he is the man you want in
this position but one versus three this
is for everything this is for the map
right now Eko making its way around the
smoke his family he rules for Taku but
that's it luminosity with a comeback
from 1510 an amazing play from coal with
the AWP all the way back into overtime
into a victory you want to hear the
really crazy part against every
expectation liquid came out guns blazing
in the second map and after bullying the
Brazilians into a 15-6 scoreline managed
to throw even harder than the first time
versus for retake with an AWP and there
it is cold is going to take his head off
and luminosity will find themselves in
the
Finals against Navi from there on out
liquid were scarred the community agreed
that Columbus had been their major to
win and that they might never recover
from such a catastrophic choke it didn't
help that they were suffering from a
slew of internal issues thanks in large
part to the very prodigy hiko himself
had worked so hard to welcome into the
team he's just he always wants to win if
he plays well and we lose and somebody
was bad like he blames that person and
he'll do it even when we live in a match
so it's something that we have to work
on something that liquid has been
helping us with some that I'm trying to
help him with and Minoo when we started
playing with the giant again before the
major we had more problems again
obviously to be expected he him and
agenda definitely don't they're not best
friends I don't think there's there's
any point of sugar go to him they're
deaf we I don't see their enemies but
you know they don't get along perfectly
but it seemed that liquid were still one
of the greatest rosters in the world and
worthy of a major title and at ESL
cologne 2016 they became the first North
American squad ever to reach a major
final but their opponent happened to be
the same team that traumatized them in
Columbus liquid never even stood a
chance and now it's just all in the
details
easy for SK to pick it up here trying to
walk through the smoke but it's just not
gonna happen SK gaming
major championship in a row they are
your winners
after that tournament naa 'test team to
date went out with a whimper instead of
a bang simple returned to Ukraine to
join Navi leaving hiko in a tough spot
obviously things didn't work out there
he went home
decided he missed his family too much
and he wanted to stay so before would
some frictions with him the team as well
yeah of course yeah ok good I mean even
though he went home and didn't come back
like even if he did come back I could
see a future where some of my players
would have refused to play with him much
longer than he actually stayed he Co was
exhausted from serving as an
intermediary for so long his performance
took a bit of a dive and liquid began to
fall off and just like that it's hiko
vs. 4 and I think it's liquid out the
door because there run good luck and
good fate in majors is a whole front and
their legendary spot it's been stolen
away a straw 'less they'll get theirs
back they'll complete our top eight
teams for the Fox Theater liquid it's a
sad finish that I run here had some good
games but suddenly being up and down
but a little bit disappointing way to
finish it off there we've got some fence
after game lots of it in an effort to
right the ship liquid dropped hiko at
the start of 2017 and it felt as if he'd
once again been robbed of his place at
the top I was so like angry about being
cut from the team because you know we
had this roster that had the talent and
had the skill and it almost wholly like
there was nothing I could do in my power
there's nothing I could have done to
made it go any differently and I just I
was really upset that we didn't really
have that chance again to to go that far
still hiko stock was high and his
devoted fanbase was hopeful that in
spite of his age
he could still find the means to compete
and succeed he refused to call it quits
and served a brief stint on optic before
Roga gave him the chance to build his
very own roster not looking good for
them akkadian trying to find some kind
of violence somehow get sidelined by
that did he go out in the open finds two
kills he still has two more in front of
them goes find a third and a fourth
hiko what the hell is that he cope
unfortunately that's to ended in
disaster
thanks to innumerable roster issues
nearly all of which were outside of his
control he co spent almost two years
trying to get his roster off the ground
unfortunately it was all to no avail and
he walked away partway through 2019
fearful about his future in
counter-strike two years ago I didn't
really have to start thinking about okay
what do I want to do after I'm done
being a pro what do I want to do once I
you know I can't play for a team anymore
but now I kind of have this this
impending thing kind of in the back of
my mind eating away at me like well what
if I don't you know I get it what if all
right if I get on a TV again then that's
great and we can deal with this later
but you know it's something now that I
have to think about more than ever now
is what what do I want to do after I'm
done playing no Kiko spent the next year
or so splitting his time between his
stream and attempting a competitive
comeback trying to crack it on a bunch
of two-bit rosters that in addition to
being a step down from what he was used
to never really amounted to anything in
spite of his reliability it felt as if
no one in cs:go was willing to gamble on
a 30-year old who never found the
success everyone felt he deserved and
while he co stream did continue to see
the same amount of moderate success it
always had it felt as if his expertise
was going to waste as if after always
managing to be in the wrong place at the
wrong time he goes chances had simply
run out and then out of nowhere as if
the gods of gaming had ordained it
something crazy happened counter-strike
saw its first real challenger like ever
I've got this
yella Sultana
hiko found a new home in valor n't and
he began to catch the attention of non
CS players who'd migrated over from a
variety of games and needed to become
fluent in the mechanics and mindset of
Counter Strike it's a he's an overwatch
player zero chance could just swing
alone you got him within no time he'd
become the entertaining educational and
wildly successful streamer he'd always
had the potential to be but as soon as
he'd gotten his hands on valor ins it
became clear that he co had always had
what it took to be a streaming
juggernaut he was personable
professional and one of those few
one-in-a-million talents who is capable
of catering to casuals and competitors
alike
oh my god I don't know why I love that I
don't know you should have heard what I
just yelled in my stream dude that was
sick but make no mistake he was still
the same cold calculating clutch master
he had always been goodbye young men
catch y'all next game catch you in the
next life for the first time in his life
it felt as if the Stars had aligned for
ego as if his time as both a content
creator and competitor had finally come
the big news is I am going professional
in valiant I have signed to a team that
team is Cola clap no stock cloud nine
I've been joining I signed with whit no
it's not liquid either I signed with 100
thieves I think it's I think some people
probably had an idea but yes I have
officially signed with team 100 thieves
whatever the future holds for hiko one
thing is certain in spite of everything
his age accolades and the awful
circumstances he's insured he's one of
these holdouts
just had to be rewarded he refused to
acquiesce and somehow someway his best
is yet to come
headshot
dude dude
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
bring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages
[Music]
you